[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
google de la phase à chaud dans les
marchés et foires bon dieu ouais vous
savez on est aux urgences ici oui j'ai
beaucoup d'idées dans la tête ça se
mélange
aujourd'hui je me trompe et c'est la
première fois qu'on le voit sociaux il
est très confiant je sais pas ce qui est
bien pour une confusion d'origine
psychiatriquement confusion d'origine
neurologique donc il faut d'abord
courant
on cherche un peu qu'on passe des
examens complémentaires pour avoir s'il
n'a pas une pathologie médicale
[Musique]
ce matin il a un tableau effectivement
très revis très agitée mais très très
incohérent ça peut faire un virage
maniaque les contours
ils étaient contents sio né sur un
brancard en fait parce que trois gîtes
et de chambres et c est en fait de
quelqu'un appelé d'entonnoir il
répondait on sait que c'était ses
proches et ça l'angoissé
donc c'est surtout pour la zone et des
stimulations et pour pour l'apaiser
match je pense que prochainement ouais
on aspire à 1930 quand on a des
situations qui sont plus complexes qui
sont plus chronophages
ça c'est sûr parce que ce rajout enfin
d'isolement social des ruptures de
parcours de soins au parti à cause du
coc vide
comment ça va monsieur je vous détacher
on est désolé mais tout à l'heure
c'était compliqué vous auriez fait du
mal si on vous avait un petit peu
contenue mais je suis contente de voir
que le traitement vous à apaiser un
petit peu voilà vous pouvez vous tourner
comme ça
d'accord sous les secours posée
l'histoire à l'air d'avoir commencé
pendant le premier confinement où il a
très très mal vécu la privation de
liberté comprenais pas pourquoi il y
avait c'est que ces règles de mise en
place pourquoi il fallait signer un
papier et cetera donc chez un patient
probablement apparemment avait un
terrain pour dépressifs même s'il a
jamais eu de problème c'est qu'à trick
plus important parce qu'après à moins
que monsieur parce que on avait dit
qu'on mettait à gergovie
mais du coup ci
cette place de gergovie team suivent à
quatre jours peut-être mettre en
patiente est moche et mettre quelqu'un
de ta mère basée dans plusieurs jeux
mais en même temps dans une chambre
double au sein de compliquer quand
viable
pour rappel simple mari et on en disant
qu' il faut absolument qu'ils nous
troupes d'élite quand ils peuvent pas
nous annoncer et roulis c'est un vrai
casse tête ça nous prend un temps ce qui
est dommage parce que c'est au détriment
de la prise en charge des patients et
tout le temps qu'on passe à chercher des
lycées du temps - au chevet des patients
au chevet des familles au niveau de
sentiments d'épanouissement
professionnel dans ce qu'on fait de
procéder tout le temps enfin d'utiliser
tout le temps des procédures dégrader
c'est extrêmement frustrant pour les
équipes